it was in this house where what's been
called a revenge rape took place the
village council leader allegedly
permitted the rape of the 17 year old
victim as punishment for her brother's
actions he said to have raped the
neighbor's daughter earlier in the month
police say they've made multiple arrests
in recent days there were about 28 or 29
culprits involved in the facilitation
and meetings the main perpetrators are
now behind bars members of the village
council were alleged to have given
permission for the revenge rape in
mid-july but the details of both rapes
only came to light later
when both families went to the police
accusing the other families son of rape
many locals say the council's actions
were a crime but they also say
Pakistan's government is partially to
blame whatever happened over there was
wrong it was because of illiteracy there
is no school or Road around so it was
the duty of the government to bring
education to this area which would
eliminate incidents such as these but
activists groups a sanctioned rape and
killings occurred throughout Pakistan
and while they're common in rural areas
they also take place and more developed
urban areas too we have seen happening
right here in Islamabad this honor
killings are done in in Islamabad and
the big cities like Karachi and lord.and
Peshawar there our honor this honor
killings happening everywhere human
rights groups are now calling for a
nationwide ban on local informal
councils they want to see immediate
improvement on an issue they see is a
nationwide shame